if you ever ask somebody
may i jerk off in front of you and they
say yes
just say are you sure that's the first
part
and then if they say yes just don't
[ __ ] do it just
just don't do it
there you go a little garlic fartfully i
told them mom was coming
really always you spread that [ __ ] all
the time right now i'll wait for this
this will kill corona corona's cousin
and every [ __ ] buck
jesus christ they took everything from
louie that was like
i don't know it might be
disproportionate i can't tell
i can't tell this is like where it's
hard to be a man
one lady said louis ck masturbating in
front of me
ruined my comedy dreams word
[Laughter]
well then i dare say madam you may have
never had a dream
either shoot ourselves or move forward
so i have to applaud louie for moving
forward
and he sold out all the shows and i
heard it was 40
women and they were up on that feet and
clapping too
if if rules are drawn out and sit down
then that's one thing but you know i
always thought the audience
would decide whether you're an
objectionable comic or even a good comic
you know and so louie went
up here at the comedy cellar and
the audience let him know i don't know
what happened i wasn't there
but uh but if the audience don't like
him
then the club won't book him i mean
that's how things work
and um
you know just because uh your heart can
break for more than one person at the
same time
you know and uh
and a person can do a bad thing
and you can feel sorry for that person
while feeling worse for the person that
had the bad thing done to them
this is all so self-evident it's
hard for me to unpack but i wanted to
use the word unpack
i believed that a path to
redemption should exist right not just
for him
i mean just for most people in in life
like people who do
bad things what about like cosby though
well okay that was really bad
my point was that is that you know
somebody gets arrested let's say
goes to jail for any number of terrible
things right
you could be accused of assault armed
robbery
murder manslaughter all these horrible
things eventually
some of those people get released and
it's like you can't just be like
that's it like you don't get to well
you're back in society now right you
have to figure out ways so
for for a lot of people they go you know
let's say somebody's accused of a
horrific
violent thing they're locked up for 20
some years they go well they did they
pay their debt to society so
they're entitled to whatever now even
though people don't have to hire them
right you know so this is obviously
not the same thing but there is some
parallel to
um there's a bad thing done
you need to pay some type of price
there's penance
involved so the you can make an argument
that you know
part of the penance is the public shame
of it all
yeah part of the penance is losing you
know
your he had big television deal with fx
that went away
touring business just stopped obviously
right so there's monetary
monetary punishment sure then you have
to go well
um if he did
you know he did admit to doing these
things it's like probably
i mean this again is just an opinion
needs to be some type of interaction
with the um people that you
or you know let them
dictate some terms of making it okay
if the legal system had been involved
it's a much clearer yeah
because path right because the whole
point is to make somebody whole again
that's the whole point of the legal
system
and um it's also like a direct
punishment so you go right you're going
to jail
you're paying a phone who's your penance
this is the penance yeah and i i think
that might be the
the biggest flaw of the metoo movement
is just like okay i get it like we're
not victim blaming
if a girl says it should happen yeah
okay it happens so let's get
what are the next steps let's let's be
very clear and specific about punishment
and and
yeah and we weren't and then that's why
this [ __ ] is not [ __ ] working now now
he's back
i think he should um you know you you
can't stop someone from doing whatever i
mean
no he you know it seems like no legal
seems like
he's i don't know it seems like he's
going to keep doing
spots i imagine what i think is crazy
actually
is that so crazy i do think it's crazy
that the clubs
um let surprise
drop-ins well in this case they
somebody should have been the gatekeeper
here and been like here's why it's nice
it's cool
it's not cool to have a polarizing
person surprise pop in right because
like cosby
yeah because then you're basically
saying that
people who are in the audience yeah
whose night
might be ruined by it you're like so
it's like dude
let them let the person i'm all for the
market
dictating what what's okay and not yeah
sure so if you go
louise on this show tonight you're
allowing audience people to go
okay i support the venue
right and the comic i'm spending my
money um
go ahead let me show you what's what
right let the consumer decide whether or
not they're on the board
you're not really letting that happen
and i know some people are like yeah but
they can get up and leave it's like yeah
you [ __ ]
no they don't want to get up and leave
you ruin their night yeah let them
figure out whether or not that's the
place they want to be
yeah can i ask you about the louis stuff
recently sure
what was your uh reaction to it he comes
back he does comedy and everybody gets
pissed off well i don't think it was
everybody it was a lot of people
yeah some people got pissed off and a
lot of people thought like
you know he's had enough let him up off
the mat
i always equate it to like you know i'd
watch a buddy of mine get into a fight i
wanted him to win
but after a while i was like all right
all right it's over you got him
like let him up i mean they took
everything from him
and like if he wants to go out and do
stand-up i mean it's a free country
you don't have to like it you don't have
to go to the go to the shows or anything
like that but um
i just wish we could get out of this i
guess we could get back to a i don't
know if that period ever existed but i
wish we could get to a period where
you could discuss things and not just
not just have to pick a well if people
start yelling at you and then try to
destroy your career
just because you have a difference of
opinion where if you're on the same page
going hey
you know this behavior is not correct
and should be dealt with and then you're
disagreeing
on type of punishment length of
punishment or anything like that
and then it just becomes like this thing
where uh
that we live in a world now where you
have to be afraid
to say that stuff it's you know to
people who are allegedly progressive
it's like how are you progressive if i
have a difference of opinion and so then
you're going to try to
destroy me is is is is the irony of that
i don't have a problem if somebody
disagrees with me i would never try to
go out
you know and and like ruin them to the
point that they're out on the street
you know um and then i also have like a
you know
there's a lot of [ __ ] where it's just
like this sounds like a job for the
authorities
and people who went to law school as
opposed to me who's just
people on twitter yeah and me like what
the [ __ ] do i know about the legal
system
i don't you know i don't know any any uh
of this stuff but like most people i do
have an opinion
and um you know
i don't have a problem if somebody
disagrees with me i would never go after
them like that
especially if they haven't done anything
other than weigh in on a
topic it's bizarre everybody on on the
internet they're just such
good people like you know without having
to demonstrate it that's what i love
like there'll be like a hashtag
i saw when it was uh things i don't
tolerate
and adults were literally weighing in on
this and then they were just saying
all of this obvious applause break [ __ ]
like racism
bigotry my favorite one mean people
say what do you [ __ ] five mean people
and that's just like like what did you
have to demonstrate
that you don't do that now is there
video of you being somewhere with a
bunch of white people and someone drops
the n-word and then you don't tolerate
it
is there any of that evidence or did you
just [ __ ]
just write a bunch of [ __ ] and it
becomes like this self-serving [ __ ]
thing
that's allegedly for the better good of
society when it really isn't
it's like all those jerk-offs on
instagram acting like they're trying to
inspire you and they're just trying to
show you all the cool [ __ ] they have
and their six-pack abs you know
i'm so [ __ ] sick of people on
instagram telling me how hard they're
working
yo we out here grinding out here trying
to get this paper just like yeah
everybody is
oh do you have to work hard in life i
didn't realize that it's just like
my favorite one i love the one too where
you bring all your cars out around the
private jet
and it's just like did you drive all
those out there yourself and you just
ubered back to your garage did that take
all day or did you did you have the
gardener drive over
the hummer i like the the labradors
stand there and you cannot be looking at
the camera you got to be looking
you got to be looking at sideways yeah
and you got to have a look on your face
this is like you know that's how we do
it man
this is oh is that how you do it i
didn't know you could do it like that
i would have done it that way had i
known how to do it
how do you do it oh we're working hard
it's just like it's like
none of this means anything it's just
it's just somebody's
trying to it's just like just just be an
arrogant ass stop acting like you're
trying to [ __ ] help me
the lebron instagram you knew the old
man in me was going to come out of
something his [ __ ] podcast
the lebron instagram workout videos like
i can't imagine
uh bird of magic doing that 30 years ago
35 years ago well in defense of him
though that didn't exist
they would have they would have been
people who did that [ __ ] bird never
would have had it bird was like tarring
his driveway during the summer it's like
bird hurt his back tarring his [ __ ]
truck because they gave you that one
standard
brush yeah i remember that i'm gonna pay
somebody seven dollars an hour to do his
driveway he's making like
a million dollars yeah how cheap come on
larry he's in the olympic village
yeah he's paying eight dollars for a
beer and his six foot nine self just
walked down the street
he was to a bar to go get a beer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh